welcome back to cbs mornings where
you've heard us talk a lot about supply
chain problems affecting your holiday
shopping but this morning we have a
story about a potential solution
at least one of the nation's busiest
ports in savannah georgia says it is
making progress on clearing its backlog
of goods by using a new concept called a
pop-up port facilities built inland to
get cargo closer to retailers more
quickly chris van cleeve spoke to
transportation secretary pete footage
about how that idea could help clear
backlogs nationwide
rural joyner's family furniture business
24e style is feeling the pinch of supply
chain delays his savannah georgia
warehouse has about half its usual
inventory so if i said i want this sofa
today
when could i actually have it in my hand
so i actually i would give you this sofa
today but if you wanted one special
ordered in a different color or whatever
it was i'd have to tell you at least six
months six months yes sir that sofa is
made in dallas but has components from
china where you had a seamless timeline
before and something that was
predictable is now unpredictable as your
costs go up
once you charge your customers goes up
absolutely i have to if i'm gonna stay
in business
joyner thinks the kinks in his supply
chain would be worse if he wasn't a
15-minute drive from one of the nation's
largest ports how out of whack is the
supply chain right now what we're
dealing with is completely unprecedented
we're still catching up as a nation to
what happened a year and a half ago when
when asia shut down griff lynch is the
executive director of georgia ports
which runs the port of savannah what
really has to happen is we've got to
grow
all of the pipeline that's going to take
a long time to fix i think we're talking
about 2022 being a tough year again
savannah longshoremen are working 24
hours a day to clear a backlog of
shipping containers in mid-october the
port had 31 ships waiting offshore
that's down to six
at its peak containers were sitting here
for nearly two weeks it's down to seven
days but that's still 75 percent longer
than normal the ports set up what
amounts to four inland pop-up ports like
this one they were unused rail yards
that expanded the port's container
capacity by 10 percent while putting
cargo closer to retailers for trucks
delivering to home depot in atlanta a
round trip becomes 70 miles instead of
440. the end of the day we're all
dealing with a parking lot and when the
parking lot is full it's full so the
race for us is to keep the parking lot
as empty as possible and keep the cars
moving out but keeping things moving
isn't easy right now the nation is
dealing with a shortage of truck drivers
the chassis the transport cargo
containers are in short supply and a
lack of sufficient warehouse space do
you feel like you're playing
whack-a-mole sometimes it can feel that
way when we're trying to solve these
short-term issues that really reflect
under-investment that's happened over
decades transportation secretary pete
budaje says the biden administration is
now studying if similar pop-up ports
could help ease congestion elsewhere at
the end of the day for folks who want to
know when these most severe disruptions
will end the answer is very simple they
will end when the pandemic ends until
then the port of savannah is expanding
adding more space for ships and cargo
its enlarged mega rail terminal can now
move one million containers a year by
train knowing there's a shortage of
truck drivers the savannah port focused
on expanding its rail service these
containers are all loaded on rail cars
that are going to head to big cities
like charlotte atlanta chicago dallas
that's one step closer to getting
products on store shelves for rural
joyner getting products back on the
shelves will mean furniture sitting in
people's homes not his warehouse
delivered without further delay for cbs
mornings i'm chris van cleave in
savannah georgia
looking for a couch scale i got one down
there i saw a little celadon green
number that looked okay okay that isn't
comforting to hear as secretary buddha
judge say it'll be it'll be better when
the pandemic is over because nobody
knows when this pandemic is going we're
going now guys into year three of the
pandemic three yep no it's the never
ending story except not entertaining
yeah yeah we're going to be starting
well we started march 2020 now we're
going to 2022. but we can go in with
optimism though all right i can't even
hope we can yeah we can't we can make
that change i actually do
nate i actually agree with you yeah
vaccinations we have boosters we are
much better off than we were in march
2020. i actually do agree with i agree
in the meantime i'm scared